And now great moments and unintended
consequences.
Part one Siege Sails
The Year 1585.
The problem the Spanish army is
besieging Antwerp.
The shelling approaching merchant
ships and causing food prices inside
the city to rise.
The solution enacts strict price
controls on food.
Sounds like a great idea.
With the best of intentions, what
could possibly go wrong?
It turns out merchants don't like
risking their lives, ships and
cargo, especially when their goods
fetch the same prices at ports
without incoming cannon fire.
Artificially low prices also
fuel demand, causing food supplies
inside the city to plummet.
It wasn't long before Antwerp
surrendered, given the city
government blockaded itself
better than any army ever could.
Part Two: Chimney Cheapskates.
The year 1662.
The problem, Charles the Second
needs more money.
The solution?
A hearth tax.
Since the number of fireplaces in a
building is considered a proxy for
wealth. This progressive property
tax scheme was sure to be a hit.
Sounds like a great idea with
the best of intentions.
What could possibly go wrong?
It turns out people don't like
paying taxes.
They also don't like petty
constables and subcontractors
entering their homes to count
stoves.
Many stuffed up their chimneys to
avoid the taxes.
One intrepid baker even knocked
through the wall from her oven to
access her neighbors chimney,
causing a fire that destroyed 20
homes and killed four people.
And since the revenue generated was
less than expected, it wasn't
long before the hearth tax also
went up in smoke.
Part Three: Cash for Clunkers.
The year 2009.
The problem a recession.
And we need to save the environment
and domestic manufacturing.
Plus, something about economic
inequality and, you know, maybe
just the reelection campaign, all
that all that was
the problem.
The solution give away $1
billion in incentives to U.S.
residents who destroy their old
vehicles for more fuel efficient
new ones.
Sounds like a great idea with
the best of intentions, what could
possibly go wrong?
It turns out people like free money.
The program blew through the
original allocation in less than a
month, so Congress approved an
additional $2 billion,
which was gone a month later.
Another thing people like driving
their new cars.
While the program did increase
average fuel economy in the United
States by .65
miles per gallon.
Total fuel consumption actually
rose more than 800 million
gallons in 2010.
As for the economy, the boost in
vehicle sales was fully offset
by a fall off once the program
ended. In fact, for every job
created, the government spent $1.4
million on the program.
But did it help U.S.
car manufacturers?
Not really. Only two of the top ten
models sold as part of the program
were domestic brands and
apparently destroying an entire
generation of used cars causes
remaining used car prices to
rise.
But hey, those are just the kinds
of vehicles less affluent people
buy, the kind donated
to charities or sold to
poor countries where they replace
even older, less fuel efficient
vehicles. And about that reelection
campaign?
Well,
I think it's important that we
consider great moments in unintended
consequences, good intentions,
bad results.
Do you have an idea for a future
episode? Put it in the comments
below. We might use them or
not. Who knows?